[Music]  all right Daniel this is supposedly the  last bond or is it the last bomb what  would it take to bring you back  god I I don't know this is gonna be my  last part I think I think I don't think  I I think I've done enough people are  gonna get sick that's sick of the sight  of me and someone else you have a go  there's been talk a woman even or the  right person for the job  you know I mean I think that's kind of  what it should be I mean I it's like  it's I'm think that's a everybody should  be considered but it's uh you know I  mean it's also but as far for women and  for South African American there should  be correct parts anyway you can across  the board it shouldn't have to be bond  that takes that you know it just doesn't  need to be bond it's it just be a need  to be written some good parts